una brecha que por el momento no ha
empezado a cerrarse de acuerdo con el
más reciente informe del laboratorio de
las desigualdades mundiales 2020 reflejó
un aumento pronunciado en los registros
de participación de la riqueza de los
multimillonarios a escala mundial
la crisis de comida exacerbado las
desigualdades entre los muy ricos y el
resto de la población de acuerdo con el
informe los llamados multimillonarios
concentran el 35 por ciento de la
riqueza mundial de los hogares pero si
bien la pandemia profundizó divisiones
la tendencia no es nueva el informe
señala que la desigualdad de ingresos y
riqueza se ha incrementado desde la
década de 1980 la mitad más pobre de la
población posee sólo el 2% de la riqueza
mundial al tiempo que el 10 por ciento
de los ricos son dueños de cerca de las
tres cuartas partes el 1% de los
multimillonarios posee el 38% en
términos de ingresos la región que
muestra mayor desigualdad fue el medio
oriente y el norte de áfrica donde el
10% más rico capta el 58 por ciento del
ingreso nacional entretanto europa se
ubica como la más equilibrada la
disparidad de ingreso también es alta
entre géneros aunque las mujeres
representan la mitad de la población
mundial sólo se llevan a casa el 35 por
ciento de los ingresos en resumen las
desigualdades globales son tan grandes
hoy como lo fue la cúspide del
imperialismo occidental a principios del
siglo 20 según el informe pero sus
autores piensan que estas brechas
podrían cerrarse a través de la acción
política y un modesto impuesto
progresivo a los multimillonarios
globales